[Music]
a lot of change
since the last time since i was a kid i
always loved hillary you know
like i love accessories it was like two
or three years ago
i was just like getting to know more
about jewelry
and you know the art all the pieces that
are here
is just one of one eighty percent of the
pieces that are here or 90
they're gonna be a museum
[Music]
we started with this one as a spinner i
sent it to murakami as a gift
he loved it so much this is how we
started the relationship
with a master murakami you know being
the first
artist to do an official collab this is
like
his most emblematic flower with the
thunderbolts that represent my brand
the working this is just amazing we made
10 of these
different colors because my album was
named colors
colors so we did h in the african color
i became a fan of murakami uh when i met
my friend
obscure my cop skill here in new york
and he just introduced me
to a lot you know i've seen it on on for
real you know and
of course about brian because but like i
didn't know a lot you know it was just
like oh
i've seen that before but then i just
started like fell in love with it
and i became friend with with because
with brian and i became friend with
with murakami like at the point that i
called them and yo let's make a change
you know let's
let's do one of one you know and they
always be nice with me
same with brian because all the pieces
from here are official
from the artist this one
is the only one in the world because
never done this before with no one
no one in the planet that has
a cost piece officially by brian in the
back says
one of one cause
[Music]
it's a blessing you know with a blessing
on a creative way you know because like
he's my favorite artist
you know he was like let's do it let's
make this piece and
it's priceless everything that you have
here is priceless and i'm not going to
talk about money in this
i'm just talking about the vibes you
know to know that this is the only piece
in the world
and that brian might call me anytime too
i need the piece to show it at the
museum you know it's just beautiful you
know
all these pieces here anytime they need
them they can use them
because it's their art so yeah this is
priceless this doesn't have a price it's
just one in the world
you're just not going to call cause and
be like i wonder i want to change
that the body has because something
beyond that you know we have
friendship it's a mutual admiration and
i want to make the statement as
latino you know to the whole world you
know to have the pieces that no one has
[Music]
this one i did it it was inspired by my
mentor pharrell
when i did colorize my album urakami
designed my happy face
so like this is my official happy face
you know like my brand
but he made his own version it's one of
one
it says takashi murakami one of one
this one was a gift from my manager i
remember just for real when he was when
he was working
basically the same size i told ben
boulder yo let's go and bring those
vibes
take it to another level this face is
dope too you know
this is the original one this is the one
we did it like this
but then we're coming designed this for
the album
and this was a gift
[Music]
on my next album you know i'm working
with khalid i'm working with a lot of
like new generation artists that i
revive with
just wanted to keep connecting the
latino culture
with the hip-hop culture and just keep
taking it to a global
space the whole tips again was my
biggest inspiration
you know on time wrong with the ping of
the og
jeff hamilton jackets and including
pharrell
you know ferrari's always been to me one
of the freshest so
i was every time i do something i show
to pharrell
this ring was inspired by for real
and when i was with pharrell in virginia
i had something in the water
i was like well i have i have this
because of you because it reminds me of
you
just having those like statement pieces
you know like
different sizes and
shapes and big things or little details
that just make the difference
it's been a lot of years a lot of years
since
jacob the jeweler has done a chain
since he got out you know i didn't
officially collab with bait
and uh when i was with nego his studio
in japan
i was checking you know like the details
the og
you know it's always been jacob you know
huge part of
the jewelry history of hip-hop and we
did it you know like
this is me that's the collab that i did
with babe so this is just
one of one two
[Music]
this one is the actual figure you know
like
you can play with it you know you open
and it's the heart inside
you change the faces you put the screw
and you change the face as well
[Music]
so shout out to taksuka and uh
gabriel from rafael and cole because i
told him like i've been working with ben
bowler that's my boy
on change you know like we we don't miss
if we're going to do a chain
we have to do something that just
elevate you as a user and
elevate my taste of what i do you go you
have
fisher that's a boy one of one if you
see another one it's not official
and it's a toy you just take it out and
just play with it you know
maybe the day i have a baby he'll be
playing with this be careful
but have fun with it i like the smiley
one
the other ones are cool you know just to
like to see and
but i like the one that is just happy
this one it's edition one of two
murakami fell so in love with this one
that he was like i need mine
and this is the official panda with
all the details the work that benbotta
did it just
out of this world you know japanese
people are really
into details same with brian you know
like the artist you know they
it's their brand on it you know so we
have to make sure that when
when i'm broken it out there his brand
and his art is just look as amazing as
the rest of his
environment you know yeah this panda is
a huge statement
it's a blessing you know to all the
biggest pop artists
in the planet you know working with us
and vibing with us and saying yes to me
and it's not about oh i have this you
know i got the money about i don't care
about that
i'm talking i'm talking about like
dreams the kid that i have inside
we're from saint saint gerard it's a
it's from lake it's another amazing
jeweler it has a technique called mosaic
all the diamonds are in different sizes
in that way
the sparkles way bigger because it's not
like
all in the same settle it's a bigger one
here it's one of here
and just make it like a lightning that's
his style it's the symbol of my city
magazine enjoy my hygiene you know
that's the name of this gimbal here and
i did it with
747 and la plaga shout out to them
you know we designed this
[Music]
this one is from the latest song that i
did magic once again
it's the same handcraft style mosaic
i used this one under canelo fight i
took him to the ring and
i was performing and i was using the mlg
one
i don't get utility to flex like that
it's not my style
it's my inner kid you know and i just
have fun with it
i don't even wear them i appreciate
the art the handcraft and i understand
completely
it's not just a piece it's art it's
something that
you're never gonna see again
you know you just oh i saw him with the
chain i said you're never gonna see it
[Music]
again
guys thank you for being here with me
jewelry's art
the collaborative pure art i appreciate
you guys thank you for your moment
latino game